okay your buddy uh he had trouble with
the homework it's okay if you did good
okay we're not not good but I'm glad you
did your homework and found you had
trouble rather than don't do you hear
why don't realize you would have trouble
if you did these questions and then
being strapped later on I will deal with
those first I'm going to uh I'm gonna
address a question which I got in the
end of yesterday which actually must
have yutori that the class by then but
it's a really good question
morning and it's counterintuitive how
simple it is it sounds like it'll be
quiet complex but what's you doing how
to do with it so what's the idea let's
just set up a scenario and then put some
questions to it okay so for instance
suppose you've got some sum sum of money
okay and it's called penny at some
fantastic all right now we're talking
about um Susan sequences so it's not
just going to compound things are going
to happen to this buddy so we're gonna
add stuff into it right so give me an
amount how much do you think for someone
who's got that amount of money
sticking a bank how much do you think
they could put in on a monthly basis
give me the book thirty bucks that's a
great so let's go the what I did to plot
dollar deposit
okay so I think that's all the efficient
yeah okay all right now if that was all
the information you were presented with
you would have to ask a question there's
something missing which you'd have to
make an assumption about can you tell me
what information is missing well it's
kind of I kind of I kind of gave you
these clues did now you'd be surprised
how many people I'm not awake at this
hour
just totally okay so I haven't told you
the content interior how often they
calculate interest right so my question
to you is we've learned other
information what assumption would you
make I had a few different ones okay on
a second so what options do we have
we've got most things you okay there's
before we go do some time what other
options do you have
what you see you like I could just pick
any arbitrary to your time right and the
answer is no you cannot it ought to be
able to solve a question you cannot for
instance even though in theory like for
an actual bank account you can do this
you could go well this question you
cannot and anyone tell me why remember
we have to solve we have that this has
to be solvable so we have to be able to
do something with this now
you're right to think okay it uh it has
something to do with time there's only
two pieces of information to you that
have anything to do with time period
right
this says parameter so there's something
happening merely this says monthly right
now which one do you think causes the
problem it's it's the fact that it's bug
for you right now why does that lock us
out in terms of solving the question
like thanks could do this right but it
locks us out of this kind of situation
why okay so you got months and they've
got 28 days for 30 days or 31 days right
and you can't make consistent
calculations on them right in the same
way whatever reasons even worse because
the number of ways varies and it's like
hot-hot weeks and it's just confusing
it's enough so if you've got monthly but
they can go into corner go into yearly
right because there are always three
months in required and they're always
talking about sever you can't which is
why by the way you're more or less you
more or less never get a question when
the club became company prune or the
poets all those recipes happen on this
failing face is precisely for the reason
that it is bitchin so all right fine
we've got these three options there
which do you think it is is my question
okay so because I heard it all by
different people let's let's go vote
right so stick your hand up if you
reckon it's yearly okay
okay thank you good for great people to
wake of the woody who records its
monthly to quarterly someone said
quarterly okay
and there are 2 4 6 8 10 12 14 16 18 20
22 23 of you which means an error sevens
confused people so by the way just for
the sake of it in that these guys are
the minority I give you guys more points
than the confuse people because commit
to something
come on people all right now which is it
which is it now if if I had no other
information okay I think probably the
majority would be right in this case I
think we would usually assume that the
company will match whatever action
you're taking which might be a deposit
or repair whatever but it doesn't have
to be it doesn't have to be okay and
that's why I'm calling this unusual
compounding periods okay so just to pay
the people who said really okay I'm
gonna say well what will happen how will
this change the question if I say that's
how they do it okay yeah sorry you I
wonder what's going on in your head up
above it when you're thinking about how
is this gonna adjust by working yeah
okay it is going to make a difference
hopefully you can see that though
obviously some kind of difference the
question is what is the difference in
this case the deposits happen more
frequently than the compound okay
now by the way this is unusual and it's
for you for the person actually making
the deposits it's actually kind of Donal
which is why this doesn't happen I will
let you try and work out over the next
10 to 15 minutes as we go through this
question why it's not a smart move okay
while we do it let's just try and work
it out let's
let's bake our goal let's make a goal
let's just get an expression for a VM
okay now and it has its own definition
usually okay but as you will see here we
can define it in a couple of different
ways we can define a rather incomplete
way so how shall we start
you've got to say this right so this is
where you begin but then because we have
a different color period versus really
would make payments right we now have a
choice you right I have one of two
choices I can say be the amount after
let's see after say the entry payment or
payment sorry it's no like so if deposit
I guess okay I guess that would be
analogous to saying after the end month
because that's how often I do deposits
okay so let's just quickly go through
this how would this word right
you always start building from the
bottom right what would aim would be
well are you do start with you 1000 and
what's going to happen after one month
after what length is the last what
things have happened well I've made a
deposit has anything else has it's a
note right because we haven't gotten to
a year yes so it just sits there okay
all right great
what happens what happens that original
1000
nothing happens to it you must always
pose this question to yourself right
because you need to be able to explain
why every number is there right and it's
also why I don't just write it like this
right even though it's true it's not
beating full expression we've lost
information it doesn't show us what's
actually taking place so I've got my two
abouts there and they represent
fundamentally different these which is
why I don't mix it up even though I can
okay so we have our one country from the
first but then one you get another
merger because it's after the second
deposit right so I could write plus
hundred but I think it's just as clear
for a writer to write I think it's still
clear where that money all right are you
getting bored yet what happens after the
third month you can't it's not a lot of
the deposit okay so can we skip a little
bit I think we can generalize just yet
because there's actions with haven't
taken place yet right but I think I can
skip a few I think I can skip 4 5 6 7 8
9 and 10 I probably want 11 just for the
sake of it what's gonna happen why is 11
in corner it's the last one that happens
before the next action right so trying
to establish the pattern alright right
so it's gonna be my original plus that
number of deposits okay good now the
action starts to happen so what would
happen here
two things are going to take place this
time right there's going to be a deposit
and then there's going to be interest
which one happens first
okay let's do it again who reckons the
deposit is first okay here we go so one
two three four five six seven five wait
what well people do you might end up
straight one two three four five six
seven eight nine gets calculated first
one to three weeks leaves which leaves
four confuse people
okay which happens first well this is
interesting because I said yesterday I
wonder if you're paying attention right
that with regard to interest that house
always wins right the bank will always
calculate interest wherever it's in its
best interests
the bank will always calculate interest
at a time when you have the least amount
of money to gain or the most amount of
money to lose right so if you're making
a repayment they'll calculate it just
before you make the repayment right sure
that the biggest amount is there and
they get kind of more interest to you
suckers right on the other hand if
they're if you're trying to make money
off them they're like why won't you pay
you as little interest as possible how
do you think I'd became a rich bank stop
by handing out lots of money to people
it's my hand you get little bit so
that's money so in the bank's interest
me to pay interest first oh okay
now I said was a GC did not I think
these people were right on the basis how
I read the questions so well done
however something funny happens I'll let
you exploit later I don't have the tons
of dude both all the way through okay
but it turns out that when you get this
good that's ends up kind of or quit the
series that you for this kind of weird
to work with okay so this will be one of
the cases if you get this situation this
will be one of the cases where your exam
centers will very likely he brought of
them leaving it up to guesswork and
saying well which do you think would be
if you had to assume they'll actually
define and they'll say something like so
I don't blame you because I didn't put
this down before cuz that would have
made it too easy they will say deposits
are made on the first day of the month
okay you'll say deposits are on the
first and interest gets calculated on
the last anchor okay so they'll actually
do that because they actually want the
batter to go in a particular direction
which you'll see shortly okay so let me
see okay sir if that's the case payment
first interest second what will happen
here well you have your one thousand are
they also one more deep in it so twelve
okay and then interest yes so this is
all going to be x
in this case 1.12 okay great
what happens next well now that the
interest has been done for the PR we
just go back to the original situation
we're now just adding a hundred dollars
on it's all of that with its interest
with this interest plus by deposit okay
and it starts got great back to its born
now remember the whole goal of us doing
this in long form is to try and see the
pattern and make sure you get the
pattern right
okay and where you can you try to skip
steps because it's like well I can see
what's going on here the pattern is
clear right how many steps to drinking
you can skip you I reckon we could go
back up to just before the interest gets
added okay because what's happening in
between there and 123 answer it's just
it's just shoveling money in and nothing
is happening okay so that would be 23
would that's before right before the end
of the second few so that'd be the
original amounts the first twelve three
payments its interest and how many more
in pivots this is this is just before
the end of the second another 11
payments okay right and then we tick
over right the year elapses okay so two
things happen number one on the payment
number two more interest so here's what
happens
there's my interest there's my final
payment my most recent payment and then
the whole lot gets interest now at this
point it's nice to become useful to us
to actually start expanding some stuff
out right because the GP is starting to
fall
she's not very obvious okay sir I'm
actually rather to have a whole bunch of
brackets I'm gonna try and get all the
terms separated out right so for
instance this $1,000 that we started
with right how many lots of interest is
it God at this particular point in time
what's got one here yeah so it's one
point one two
sweat okay now this was the first 12 rib
payments we made during that first year
how many lots of interest it doesn't
have it's also got to because it's got
the same Vista so it's got twelve times
one hundred times one point one two
sweat humour the repairs from this year
okay all of them together how much
interest has been added with one one
batch okay this is better but my series
is still kind of obscured here what can
I do to make it really really obvious
well here I'm going back as step in
factoring
what would I take out I could take out
and 12 and the 101 put more to take them
all out they're all coming so I'll get
this twelve 101.1 okay what's happening
in here now as you see before it often
is useful in these kinds of situations
to write the series in Reverse right cuz
that's it's gonna grow so how many lots
of them here here this one only one side
a key there's another one extra littler
- here's my series for me okay now what
was this this is a 24 eirick and we
could go to 36
your original thousand how many lots of
interest doesn't have after thirty six
months three lots okay what's happening
in here this is all the same too but now
the series is growing you've got the
first line or the first twelve months
the next twelve months and then the most
recent 12 right now let's see this is
the right question why is this a dumb
way to go why is it that people really
if they if you get told okay
I'm gonna call her annually whatever
period right I'm not gonna pay monthly
totally a crazy man would pay more
frequently there's no benefit in fact is
worse than no benefit now in case you
were following he is the critical point
you wanna watch for what's going on here
we skipped all these months conveniently
because mathematically nothing
interesting was happening right but
mathematically nothing interesting means
financially nothing interesting right
it's like Oh
shoveling money into this I don't have
access to it anymore and what benefit am
I getting out of them
nothing it's just sitting there not
working for me right I might as well
just have that in my own bank account
getting some interest rather than in
this weird sort of superannuation setup
which is not doing very much grateful so
in between 3 and 11 in between 13 and 23
right just it's just sitting there right
so you might as well save up all your
money use it to go like buy cool stuff
and then put it right before they
compound right because that's what it's
actually gonna have some benefits to you
whereas you're like losing money every
month
inside I don't know this access to it
but it's not possible only benefit
you're not spending it so maybe that's a
good thing
alright now I rank it from here we
almost could go and then cooing okay but
Amon is actually not that interesting
because as we've seen it's a whole bunch
of in where it's really boring him right
and nothing the series is actually not
progressing for a lot of those values of
n which values have been unuseful it's
only the factors as well that's where
something interesting is happening so
you can do this
you could do this okay so what would
happen
well after 48 then before and that'd be
three and so on
let's generalize your name you're gonna
have this guy what will the power be
it looks like this is the number of
years and this is the number of months
right and that's because that's when it
compounds you see where the thumb isn't
they giving you meaning okay so this is
an end what's going on to here all of
this is the same every single time right
and how serious is growing for the end
three then two there and here and minus
one man okay so then good I have
generalized down I can do one more thing
right you can kind of see it's like
really interesting how things are
happening on multiples of 12 are kind of
not interested in the rest of them right
so therefore and sorry not just that but
the multiples of 12 don't really appear
you know it's kind of immaterial to
expression so you might like to have
defined a event at the beginning to be
something different what I define that
the amount after the in deposit Lien's
month right but months of boring
nothing's happening why do we pick
something more interesting like the end
a year now so is not to invalidate all
the one you just put down and bind to
okay let's define it as something
different for now Mike let's well what
should we call it it's every year let's
call it why why then let's let that baby
bounce after the
you can see it right now you can sort of
now that we've built it you see what's
going on I can immediately say look
Chinese why isn't it why have one after
a year what's happened you started with
your own GD balloon now and then you had
after year 12 repentance nothing
happened to any of those you hate until
the very very end and it got injured
then you can do y 2 y 3 and you can
generalize Y end from there ok so you
can see for a question like this wait
have choice you saw will do more or less
what opinion would you choose right now
obviously it takes a bit more thinking
to make sure you like okay do which one
what happens first it all that kind of
thing right but the point is you can
pick and there are schmuck choices and
their own I should say efficient choices
and less efficient choices okay this is
probably not the efficient one but at
least it was obvious okay
eventually you got secured you're like
oh I see what's happening 36 48 those
ones that are interesting too okay I'll
go place your question we already
decided okay pretty dumb to pay more
often that you're compounding okay well
how about we pay less often right so
rather be exactly the same rather than
this being more frequent than that what
if it's the other way around this is why
I made it per person
monthly and let's go now since I suppose
you can say we get up for combos let's
make it 200
okay now call that sense tells you this
will be different again the question is
how it'll be different
now by the way just before you guys
stopped working unit and form your own
do you're in so you can get to an A or a
wired or whatever why would you do this
why would you pay less frequently why
would you let them get away with
compounding so many times and only pay
at the end why might you do know okay so
you're still like a hero to me so rather
than wait until the very end it's like I
finally have the whole song I might
it'll still have some kind of regular
payment right
my question is why why not make it why
don't make it match why not have it if
that's monthly like as I can sort of
choose right where I company in I give
an example even though it's not
practical for us I rubbed it off already
banks calculate interest daily all of
them daily
okay so so they're compounding daily now
I have a mortgage but I do not pay it
off daily I'm gonna pay off that $5
every day
it's it's a waste of time what I go into
the bank and that is true but guess what
I don't do any of my own have to spend
any time doing any my parents it's all
set up it just doesn't seem all that you
have to think about that
there's a really obvious answer when you
think about it but it's tricky I suppose
because well how many of you work Who am
I kidding is the top class you know type
of work that's a big clue by the way so
I have two questions for you number one
how is this gonna form a different thing
at the india my question number two why
would you do that why would you pay less
frequently than the companion food okay
there's many questions for you off you
go